a lot of experience or even some
experience with sort of packaging in
Python or using git and github or just
basic ways of sharing a distributing
code this really isn't directed at you
but I think a lot of people are doing
really interesting things with Python in
writing scripts to do various like
mathematical or scientific computation
or data science like things but they
really don't know how to share that code
beyond their own computer and the reason
I think that is because that's where I
was very much when I was in grad school
which wasn't that long ago and a lot of
my fellow grad students were like that
and I wish I had had more motivation and
direction to share things that I was
working on it so that's that's why I'm
here and what I'd like to talk to you
all about so just a little bit of my
personal history if you don't count
ti-basic I learned a program reading
this book in high school to build Lord
of the Rings fan sites with PHP and my
sequel and probably for everyone's
benefit none of that code exists at all
today and and back then there really
wasn't
this was pre github there weren't really
easy ways to even share code with people
but you know everything I did there
lived on my own machine and no one ever
saw that and college I did a lot of
interesting things I studied math and
computer science and all the interesting
projects at least the ones that still
live on from college only exist in this
folder in my Dropbox on my computer and
no one no one's ever seen the C++ that's
pasted in Word documents which is also
probably a good thing but you know I I
remember doing this really interesting
interesting to me report on
approximation methods for the Traveling
Salesman problem that if I were doing it
again today I would really like to be
able to share with the world because I
think more people would be interested in
it than just my professor so this was
the first thing I ever put on breath on
github when I was in grad school at NC
State
it's a mathematic anote book on
simulated annealing tragically get-up
doesn't render Mathematica notebooks but
as you look at this you also notice
there's like other than this description
in the math and the github description
thing class project to visualize
simulated annealing there's nothing here
about how to run this what dependencies
it might have you know what it might be
good for how others might use it how
others might even start to just look at
it because if you click on these it's
its Mathematica notebooks are less
readable than like Jupiter notebook
files so it's essentially useless to
anyone and really the whole premise of
my talk here is that this doesn't really
have to be the case and it doesn't need
to be the case for you and the other
side of that is this was actually a
pretty interesting thing like so I
implemented simulated annealing from
scratch which isn't that hard but you
know it's neat to walk through and
mathematic has really powerful ways of
doing visualizations and if I had taken
the time to figure out how to turn this
into HTML and like render gifs which is
really easy to do with Mathematica this
could have been like a really cool thing
on my website for people to see and said
it's this github project that has one
star which you see is my star
no one's forked it you know no one's
watching it you know it probably no one
has ever looked at actually open these
notebooks so today you know I'm still
figuring all this out but maybe arguably
one of my more successful projects is
this little tool for helping you deploy
a Python bot to AWS lambda which allows
you to basically I'm sorry a Twitter bot
using Python on AWS lambda which allows
you to have a Twitter bot that doesn't
need a server to run on and a small
number of people have found it very
happy or have been very happy using it
and have found it very useful and in
some part that's just because I've
learned how to do this better and people
are benefiting from the things I've
learned of how to
how to share projects if anyone wants to
see these slides by the way the link in
the bottom left corner will these are on
Google slides you can pull this right up
I'm gonna have a bunch of links here
coming up and so even later you might
want to pull that up bitly dot or bitly
/ pi dated 2016 so this is again my
premises I suspect if anyone's here at
PI data you also do interesting things
you've done some sort of interesting
data analysis maybe even you've just
done sort of a toy problem but you've
done visualizations that differently
from someone how someone else has done
it or you have your own special domain
that you work in and there's some open
data set that you've looked at that
people aren't really looking at in a
more public way and your your
potentially doing all that on your
computer and maybe telling your
classmate or co-worker about it but no
one's really getting to see it so if you
take away one thing from this talk my
desire would be for you to have some
more confidence to take the kinds of
things that you probably do in your free
time because because the things I do in
my free time and share those with the
broader audience and the rest of this
talk is just trying to give you a little
bit of what I've learned of things that
are valuable to make that happen I'm not
going to go into a lot of the technical
details largely the takeaways here are
going to be things that you can go and
learn further in your free time and I've
tried to provide some links to help you
with that the first thing is the reality
is you just need to learn how to use get
and get is a difficult thing to use but
but you really need to know how to use
it and I procrastinated for a long time
for doing that but it's how software is
exchanged these days so even in your
personal projects you should try to
think about learning to use get in in a
way that in the future you know if
you're not using it with other people
right now start to learn about how you
could use it in a way that you could
eventually work well with other people
because it's really easy to use it in a
very sloppy way on your own that isn't
gonna work well when you need to use it
with the team code school has some
tutorials the first one is free they
can walkthrough on how to use get it's
an interactive tutorial on their website
I think these other ones you have to pay
for but I'm just that is a really good
start this jiff is relevant to anyone
who's ever used to get their doubt and a
great TV show but something that confuse
me way longer than I would really like
to admit is understanding the difference
between git and github and so
understanding that is going to be also
really important for you and that could
be a whole talk on itself but github
also has a nice page on how to use
github but but basically github is built
on top of git and it's a remote
repository for managing your source code
but yet could could communicate with all
kinds of different remote repositories
like bitbucket
or lots of other things even Heroku if
you deploy a website to Heroku basically
functions in that way but github is what
people use and and you really just need
to know about it to go back to the title
of this talk making or github the best
resume it can be that was a little bit
designed to draw you in here there's a
lot of controversy over the idea of your
like your github as a resume you look at
my github it's like 90% unfinished
projects which maybe actually reflects
my work life better than I was more than
I'd want to admit but I don't know that
hub should really be considered your
resume as people have said but the
reality is if you're interviewing for a
job people are going to go and look at
it and so if you can make it be
attractive and inviting and make it look
like you're doing a lot of interesting
things versus you know one time you fork
scikit-learn five years ago you know I
think that's worth doing so it's it's
ultimately to your own benefit pool
request you know this is an example
that's a weird term if you don't know
what that means just go out and start
learning some of the terminology around
github and everyone here is smart enough
to really understand how it works but
you just have to force yourself to sit
down and get over the hump I think that
was the what was true for me
so our next piece of advice I have for
you as you're thinking about a project
um you're analyzing some interesting
data over the weekend and you just did
it for your own curiosity you pulled a
data set think about writing or readme
to go with and there's actually this
interesting idea that people have called
readme driven development and the idea
there is you know so people talk about
test-driven development and all these
different things but the idea there is
go write down clearly and in in in
paragraphs what you're trying to do and
what this thing that you're working on
is trying to accomplish and you'll find
it's also very helpful just for moving
you forward in your own project and it's
also going to be valuable for other
people who are looking at your project
later on so think about you know you're
working on some interesting code you're
working on the simulated annealing
project write three paragraphs about
what it does put a heading that says you
know installation or dependencies and
write how you get it to run and then say
oh here's here's how you can see the
example code and in 15 minutes you have
something that makes your project go
from basically being useless to other
people to at least allowing other people
to know if it's something that might be
valuable to them maybe show some example
output from your code if that's an
appropriate thing if if something is a
toy project it's okay to express that
say hey I just worked on this just to
teach myself this you don't want to use
this in production but just just to
clear kind of what's people what you're
doing and put it in a file called readme
MD and when people load your github
profile that's gonna show up right on
the front of the project this is a link
to I think the original article this
idea of readme driven development it's
worth reading there are some other
people who have written along the same
lines if you're putting software online
the reality is you you should seriously
consider licensing it and I am
definitely not a lawyer
but as best as I understand it if if you
put software online and it has no
license in the United States it's
considered copyrighted and no one can
actually use your code and it's
potentially illegal for someone to even
copy and paste a little snippet of your
code you probably don't want that to be
the case and so you can license it by
attaching a license file to it I think
this is an official github site choose
the license com if I'm not 100% sure
that oh my well this is my animation is
defeating me but this is a license I
have on one of my project notes on dear
Shelley processes this is an MIT license
and to add a license to get hub all
you're doing is copying and pasting text
basically into a file called license IMD
and that's considered the acceptable way
to to license some software let's see if
I can get to that link well choose a
license com is going to walk you through
how you can choose a license to put with
your with your project you can read
through it for yourself but it's a
really helpful way to get started it
tells you some projects that have
various licenses if nothing else you can
put a you can put a public domain
license guess on here they have an
unlicensed but you can declare on your
in your code put some text in and say
you can use this for whatever you want
you can make money off this you don't
even have to attribute it to me you
should consider doing something like
that I've done that with some projects
it's a small thing but it it's a
potentially a very important thing and
it potentially allows people to use the
things that you're working on and the
things they're working on and you could
require them to attribute them back to
you and it makes you look good and maybe
makes everyone win
so another valuable thing you can do is
include some runnable examples
including ipython or jupiter notebooks
is something people have been doing a
lot recently there may be some
limitations to that but I think it can
be a really nice a nice thing a
limitation is for example they don't
differ well in your get thing so it's
hard to do version history on a notebook
another thing is if you have a notebook
and I guess this is true with any
examples but your your notebook could
get out of date with the rest of your
projects you have to force yourself to
update your examples as you're updating
your code but oh all that to say I think
it's it's a really nice way to do this
project I really like is PI LD a vis so
this is a way for visualizing Linde
really allocation topic models ways of
looking at categories of text it's based
on an r package but it's kind of been
maybe out of Utah writes this and it's
you can just go pip install it and then
you can get really beautiful
visualizations of your topics and topic
models but so to start with it you know
you load this github page and he has
this really nice readme so everything
you're seeing here is just text in his
his readme file you can see the raw file
right so this is just the text file that
he has as a readme as a restructured
text file and github is going to render
that on the the front page of his
project so if this was me a few years
ago I would have done this thing and had
all this nice code and then you would
have loaded this and you would have just
seen this big index of all the code
that's available here and I would have
written nothing about how you use it or
how you run it and it would have been
useless to everyone but if you put a
readme file then get hub renders it you
know you can look quickly and see what
this thing is supposed to do you know
even has a bad showing that it's on pi
PI so you can pip install
a bad joke has build his failing on
Travis or something and that his docks
are updated I'll read the docks you can
learn how to do these things so they
update automatically it's reading me
that's really nice instructions on how
to install and he doesn't have really
thorough documentation on how this thing
works
I guess he well so he does have basic
documentation I read the docs maybe it's
actually better than I remember so it's
not it's mostly just a change log that
he has on read the docs but he's
included this really nice jupiter
notebook which he links to and it's just
the file committed in the github
repository and with text and code he
walks through how you use this project
that he has so you can on NB viewer you
can go and just look at this thing in on
and be viewer I might get hub renders
the the JavaScript so you could even see
how it visualizes the topics right on
here and then also you could download
the notebook and then you could interact
with it yourself yeah the code is
available so you can rerun the notebook
you can modify it and learn from his
example so there it's a very interactive
way to understand the code so you know
you're doing something some interesting
data visualization or training a machine
learning model or something in your own
free time we're looking at data in a new
way you put together this notebook and
then you can put that online and other
people can go and download that and look
into it there's another project called
binder which actually binder allows you
to add a badge right on to github and
when you click it it spins up a virtual
machine that allows you to interact with
the notebook without even cloning it to
your computer so this is my binder org
they have some example projects so on
the on the readme there's a button that
says launch finder I don't know if this
will we can get this the certain time or
not but it's actually gonna create a
virtual machine
installed the dependencies the Python
dependencies using the requirements file
and then launch the notebook right here
for you to see so you can imagine again
back to my terrible example from grad
school I did this really cool thing to
turn into my professor and I've probably
got a fine grade on it
but that's fine that's basically as far
as it went but if I done it in a
language that wasn't proprietary and I
had known more and been motivated more
of how to share this I could have taken
this thing and how to link to it
straight from my about me page on my
blog or put it on my Twitter or LinkedIn
or something in a few years down the
road I'm applying for a job and people
go you know start clicking on it like oh
this guy's really smart he knows how to
implement simulated annealing himself
instead of oh here's this huge file that
is meaningless to me
right so we can now like look straight
in this binder file so you could you
could do this with your own project as
long as it can install the dependencies
for pip it's really cool very powerful
thing very powerful way to work all
right so this is a really important
thing and also should be a talk or a
seminar or a class on itself but I think
in working on your side projects you you
really need to think about always being
engineering that software and what I
mean by that is it's very tempting for
us to write something thinking we're the
only one who's ever going to see it and
so I can use X or X X and then like X X
X is all my variable names or x and y
and z and you know write these horrific
nested list comprehensions in Python
that that no one's ever going to be able
to dissect but I I think it's it's
really worth thinking I mean it's almost
a self-fulfilling prophecy right no
one's gonna see this software you're
probably going to end up writing it in a
way that you're not ever gonna be able
to share with anyone because it's going
to be incomprehensible at the same time
in your work if you're
you're out of school and you do
something like that and in your work
it's like a joke to say no one's ever
going to see it at some point you're
gonna have to hand that off to someone
else so my recommendation is is even
when you're doing something on the side
or something quick like try to be
thinking about how to write that using
good engineering principles a huge thing
that we all do is is have these magic
constants so we the worst example this
is we have hard-coded file paths all
throughout something so we need this
data and so we just have these
hard-coded file paths so that is
impossible for it to run on any other
machine that doesn't have the exact same
user name and file structure as your
computer right so if nothing else think
about hey I'm not gonna hard code these
file paths I'm going to put the file
paths as a defined constant at the top
of my code so if there's nothing else
people can just come in and change that
content and then run it or just another
example of a magic constant just like
using numbers that make sense to you but
they don't someone else reading it might
not understand it so give your numbers a
name by signing them to a variable and
then use them or something like that use
the script the variable names we've all
written things that's really bad single
character variable names and other bad
things think about right
writing reusable code put things into
functions so that you can call the
function instead of copying and pasting
just just kind of basic things force
yourself to think about that and that's
the right thing you know maybe it
doesn't make sense for you to write that
the first time but but force yourself to
say okay I got this to work now I'm
gonna go back and try and put this in a
way that makes more logical sense ER
that's more maintainable thinking about
writing more functions and use good
names for your functions instead of just
writing this thousand line script that
doesn't call any of your own functions
split things up into meaningful chunks a
paper was just put on online called good
enough practices and scientific
computing this would probably be a
valuable paper for a lot of people but
they have a big outline of the points of
their paper number two is
tips for software engineering
essentially some of these things were
already talking about give functions and
variables meaningful names make
dependencies explicit this is probably
you know if you can consider what you do
scientific computing at all this is
probably worth going through because
once you turn on animations you can't
then click links so
yeah so here's that whole paper and
that's just the second paragraph in it
and it's a whole long paper they flesh
out each point in that outline and then
the outline has things on data
management software collaboration
project coordinate organization keeping
track of changes manuscripts a lot of
the things we've been talking about here
you know go and read through that and
teach yourself that and overtime trying
to implement more of those things in
your own practice it's gonna pay off all
of us are probably going to end up
writing code for jobs in the future even
if you're at school and you know maybe
you're not planning to be a software
engineer but you're planning to be a
scientist or something you're probably
getting enough writing code I guess you
know today is the data to stop the
generational bad habit of writing
terrible and on maintainable code that
that we've all learned in grad school
declare your dependencies this is
actually something that's been
particularly frustrating to me at PI
data as it pi did in New York City last
year and people are doing tutorials and
they're putting their ipython notebooks
online and they're not even telling us
what version of Python they're using
right so we have two different versions
of the language that the syntax isn't
even completely compatible they're
saying here go run this thing and you're
not even telling me what interpreter DS
run I mean that to me seems like a very
basic thing people aren't thinking of
that so you need to declare your
dependency starting with your Python
interpreter and then otherwise learn to
use virtual environments or I would
argue for conda environments learn to
write requirements files or conda
environment files I have found over the
last year conda environment files a
really nice oricon environments and the
environment llamó files a really nice
replacement in many cases to virtual
environments among other reasons it
allows you to specify what version of
Python you're using so here's an example
kondeh environment file you're naming
your environment or
justifying your dependencies it's not
just Python packages it's any binary
that's on the Anaconda repository you
can specify the version is Python 3 and
you can also specify requirements from
pi pi using this this pip something and
then you can run that as I have here
Conda M create and then you can specify
the environment file and it's going to
create this virtual environment that's
gonna have all your dependencies and
it's going to be separated from any
other dependencies you have on your
system wide Python it's a really really
nice thing so my work I work at a
company called distill networks or a
computer security company and on our
research team we do a lot of small
research projects and we have this huge
github repository that has a folder for
every project it roughly corresponds to
JIRA tickets so when we start a new
project we created this fuller folder
with the JIRA ticket number and then I
have a script on my system that
automatically creates a Conda
environment file named after the folder
and then adds the dependencies I use in
most things and that way when we are
running each other's code we don't have
to actually know what version of Python
someone use on this research project you
just go into the directory and say Conda
impe create and Conda is going to
install whatever version of Python it
needs and install the dependencies and
then you can type ipython and all of a
sudden you're being able to run the code
not caring whether or not there are
parentheses around the print statements
I have found this to be one of the most
beneficial tools I've had in the last
year and my team has found it really
helpful if you haven't looked at it I
would encourage you to do that that's
through continuum you can search
continuum anaconda or Conda and find out
how to do that people are critical at
times of this idea of idiomatic code or
pythonic code my opinion is it's worth
learning how to sew
right code in a way that the Python
community at large has deemed valuable
and readable and and good for the
community if nothing else if you decide
you want to break the rules at least
know what the rules are first it's kind
of how I look at it a really valuable
thing you can be doing is read good
books a Python cookbook really nice book
and fluent python is a book specifically
about like what are the nuances of
Python that really set it apart as a
language if you've come to Python from
another object-oriented language you
probably write what a lot of people were
considered to be very bad Python I came
to Python having done a lot of C++ in
college having done some Java and I
tried to write all my Python in the same
way I tried to create a class for
everything and ended up just writing
this terrible bloated unreadable Python
code and over the years I've learned to
write Python in a way that makes me
happier makes the people I work with
happier it makes my code easier to read
and maintain and and I think it's worth
learning some of those ideas and
concepts another great thing you can do
is get feedback one of the most
beneficial things for me was taking my
second job out of grad school I worked
with a lot of Python programmers for the
first time before that I had been kind
of doing Python on my own and people
were very critical of the things I was
working on and I learned so much and I
was able to develop a lot and now I get
to be the critical one of my co-workers
so it's great if you're in the area we
have the Python meetup Chris I see Chris
in here Chris who's one of the hosts of
this event runs that and it's it's a
great group and you can go and work on
things and let other people see it and
let other people give you feedback in
and be willing to be told you're wrong
or that you can do things in a better
way
my old boss and Ramon Silencio parsley
who's a sometimes a PI data speaker has
a document called the elements of Python
style
is kind of how parsley has has learned
to write Python it and this is a really
good document and again you know it's
not the law you don't have to fall at
every point but it I am strongly the
opinion that it's worth hearing what
other people have to say it's on github
elements of Python style you can google
it and find it read through it think
about that
another thing to consider is learned how
to write command line tools this seems
like a daunting thing but there are a
number of Python libraries that makes
writing command line tools pretty easy
it's a way that you could allow other
people to interact with your code
without having to actually modify or
edit your code so for example you need
to specify a file path to write this
code write a little command line tool
that just takes the file path as a
command line operator and then does the
analysis I really love click it's
there's a little bit of a learning curve
to get used to it but it ends up
allowing you to write really nice code
to do to make a command line tool so
it's using Python decorators to specify
the arguments and you can do things like
this there are a number of other
alternatives and you can look into but
this is one I've really enjoyed using
tools like fabric which is does more
than this but you can encapsulate
different commands and fabric or using a
make file here's an example of something
I've done in a little project I have so
this is a make file and it allows you to
create these commands which is the word
before the colon and then it'll just run
a bunch of things all together if your
project has to run a bunch of different
scripts or a bunch of different commands
trying to capsulate all those commands
don't make people just go and copy and
paste it under stuff that gets really
annoying this is a nice short article
writing command line tool in Python in
under 60 seconds
I recommend going through
alright so also you something that I put
off way too long it's using is learning
to use setup tools to make something
installable in Python so for a long time
if I wanted to import something I would
just you know copy and paste or make a
symlink or something with the folder the
code that I needed to import and it took
me way too long to be able to to learn
how to use setup tools so you can do
Python setup I install and then install
the module into your environment so that
you can import it it's not it's not as
hard as you might think
and it's worth just sitting down some
weekend and just figure out how to do it
so instead of trying to write
instructions on your github project for
people like oh here go copy and paste
this code into this directory and then
you can import it you can tell people
they can just do get clone your project
and then see the end of the project and
the new Python set up at PI install and
it'll make it imported well there's a
really nice tutorial again this is just
for you to go look at later but it's not
an example pipe I project this will
include using setup tools and then also
deploying that to pi PI the Python
package repositories have been not only
can you do Python setup I install but
someone could just do pip install and
then it'll go grab it from pi PI which
is only one more step really beyond
using setup tools largely as a
concluding thing I would commend to you
there's something called the cookie
cutter project this is actually the the
template for Python but cookie cutter is
a project that allows you to create a
whole folder structure and like the
default files and things you need to for
a development project in all kinds of
different languages so their sample
cookie cutters or
cookie-cutter types down here a flask
project a pet project a Python package
and a lot of it's Python but there are
things in other languages sublime text
plug-in does Django project C++ project
all these different things and it
provides it you pip and solid it's a
Python thing and it gives you a
command-line tool called cookie cutter
and you say cookie cutter and then
reference the the github repository you
want to create as to use as a template
so I'm gonna try and walk through an
example of this so there's this cookie
cutter Python package repository so we
can run cookie cutter and then specify
the repository and see if the internet
lets this work but it's going to clone
the repository and then it's going to
create a Python project using that as a
base for the project so once know my
name my email address my github username
I'm just going to use leave the default
project name the description my PI P I
user name is also TD hopper the the
version number that you want to start
your project with do you only use PI
test or not I really like PI test for
doing unit testing doing a deploy to PI
P I using Travis it's a little bit more
of an advanced thing but that's how you
can automate if your software passed a
test you can automatically update it to
pi PI we're gonna say no for now and
then do I want to create a command-line
interface using click which I just
talked about I really like click so
let's go ahead and do that create an
author file I'm just gonna have one
author so I'm not going to do that and
then it's even gonna let me choose a
license and MIT license I often go with
so we're gonna go and do that so this
created a directory for me called Python
boilerplate which was the default name
if you open that which didn't exist
before I don't know how to make the text
bigger but
it created this folder called Python
boilerplate and it all of these files
are things that it created and it's a
little bit overwhelming that you need
all of these files for a Python package
but it starts to make sense once you you
learn it so the core code is in here in
the Python boilerplate folder here's our
basic command line interface here's the
Python boilerplate which is where you're
going to start writing your code and
created a basic test holder that you can
use to to start writing some tests
there's a readme that you can go in and
update to have the things you want a
history file for you to keep a version
history a list of our instructions on
how people can contribute and then
importantly it's going to give you a
basic set up pi file so you could
already go on this project and we could
say pip and well and so now we could go
we could launch Python and say import
Python boilerplate right so we've
already imported our the module that we
just created so if you've been working
on a script that does something you
could take this and start to integrate
your script right in here
it's going to have the make file it's
going to have some commands that you can
use to build the documentation so you
could upload this to read the docs it'll
run your tests for you using talks you
can it has a you can type make release
and it's going to release it to pipe I
for you it's just going to automate a
lot of this stuff so all of these things
are you know opens lots of doors of
things to learn but this is a really
nice place to start go and start to
learn what these various things do see
what happens when you modify various
things I've found this to be an
extremely valuable project
I'm about out of time this is just a
recap slide of my recommendations but I
would like to go and take any questions
that were able to take Jenny as the mic
there so we're only gonna do a couple of
questions because our birds of a feather
are gonna start so while you're thinking
of the questions I want to let you know
that they unarmed the security doors
until five o'clock so you can leave
through those doors until five o'clock
and the birds of a feather are going to
be out under the tents and if you go to
the bloomix group you can find out where
they are so how about some questions for
Tim I'm happy to field questions
tomorrow or dinner tonight and you can
email me or your lightning talk about
Ibis yeah there is one more slot for our
lightning talks if folks get out there
quickly you can sign up how about we
dismiss them - sure and then you guys
can talk to him up here thank